[Music]
n Open the internal and external use of Cheongju Seok Haneuljae Senses One-to-Dae Sean Up
Mac in Knee Up Energy Give it like a coke in Shake
My name is Kang Bong-seok,
and I’m working on a theory Korea  I'm making a candy that I've pulled out of Dawn's [ __ ],
this oh my it's Park 0 My son's South el stew beans
linc Follow the station in Korea, the process is a bit more studied and eaten, and after I
cleared it, I was able to withstand 50% of my height and was made with
it.  From generation to generation, I am about 140 years
old. When I was a grandfather, my mother knew that my mother would be an empress, and
my father taught me how to make a kite. For many
years, when my grandfather and father were doing
[music],
I made it by compensating for the old traditional method.
I'm thinking about adding ginger and adding a single word of pumpkin to the bellflower, I've been thinking about making a few places over the years.
I was embarrassed for a certain amount of time with the added value mixed with each other. After making a conversation, I
got rid of the aspect and
burned with fire.
After that, it’s a process I’m still
thirsty for.
Why is the process of daenggi making him excited? It's just that the black female form is
hard.
When I was young, I knew a lot of people, and also my father taught me how to make candy
.
[Music]
I think it's right to cry before continuing the battles we received from
our ancestors' Switch and our phones and grandfathers.
]